merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame et monsieurs le les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues au début
de l'examen de ce texte nous avions une
crainte assez rare dans cet hémicycle
que nous ne parvenions pas à un accord
sur l'ensemble du texte en en mars
dernier la discussion avait été riche
lors de l'examen en commission et elle a
été également en séance la semaine passé
aujourd'hui nous sommes satisfaits que
nous puissions adopter un texte sur une
problématique aussi importante pour nos
concitoyens notre assemblée aura fait
œuvre utile et c'est tant mieux le texte
que nous nous apprêtons à voter a bien
changé depuis son dépôt sur le bureau du
Sénat le 1er février il s'est d'abord
étaufé le nombre d'articles additionnels
que nous avons adopté est assez
inhabituel cela montre d'abord une chose
la version initiale du projet de loi
présenta plusieurs manques que notre
Assemblée a bien voulu combler le texte
ne prévoyait rien en matière notamment
de regroupement familial de contrôle de
l'immigration étudiante alors que des
évolution était indispensable nous
aurions aussi voulu aller plus loin sur
un sujet brûlant des mineurs non
accompagnés mais certains de nos
amendements ont malheureusement été
frappés de l'article 40 il était aussi
nécessaire de renforcer le rôle du
Parlement nous avons souhaité qu'il
puisse fixer dans le cadre d'un débat
annuel et pour chaque des catégories de
séjour à l'exception de l'asile le
nombre d'étrangers admis en France enfin
les débats en séance ont permis d'aller
plus loin sur certains aspects du texte
notamment à la lumière de l'actualité
dramatique de l'attentat d'aras le Sénat
a ainsi facilité la levée des
protections contre les expulsions et les
interdictions du territoire français en
en supprimant certaines et en
généralisant la possibilité de les
prononcer nous nous avons également
rétabli en séance l'obligation pour un
employeur de prendre en charge les frais
de formation à l'apprentissage du
français certains aménagements ont
suscité des doutes ou des des réticences
au sein de notre groupe c'est notamment
le cas des dispositions de l'article 1er
n adopté en séance prévoyant de
conditionner l'ouverture des droits aux
prestations social non contributive à 5
années de résidence stable et régulière
je rappelle qu'il s'agit des allocations
familiales de la prestation de
compensation handicap ou encore de
l'aide personnalisée au logement pour
plusieurs membres de notre groupe ce
délai de 5 années est trop long si
aujourd'hui ce dégalage existe déjà je
rappelle qu'il n'était que de 6 mois et
que nous l'avons étendu à 5 ans de la
même manière la modification de l'aide
médicale d'État a suscité certaines
réactions pour autant ce débat va se
prolonger à l'Assemblée nationale et en
commission mixte paritaire mais si nous
pouvons être honnêt il y a une part de
mauvaise foi des deux côtés ceux d'abord
qui nous annoncent de manière
tonitruante que nous avons supprimé et
que c'est très bien que nous l'avons
supprimé et que c'est très bienin ne
rappelle pas toujours que nous avons
surtout changer son nom en aide médicale
d'urgence et réduit ainsi son panier de
soins de même ceux qui s'indignent de
l'inhumanité de cette suppression faut
aussi semblant de ne pas voir que cette
aimu qui en réalité ne laissera personne
mourir d'une pathologie grave sur notre
sol qu'il soit français ou étranger en
situation
irrégulière un compromis je rappelle
n'est pas une comprimion compromission
mes chers collègues ils font donc
revenir des deux côtés des deux côtés à
plus de sérénité et arrêter les
déclarations trop radicales qui ne
reflètent pas ce que le Sénat a
réellement
votter enfin nous saluons l'accord qui
est intervenu au sein de la majorité
sénatoriale sur la question des métiers
en tension personne ne voulait ni au
groupe LR ni au groupe UC de la création
d'un titre de séjour créant un droit
opposable à la régularisation nous en
sommes sortis par le haut et je tiens à
saluer particulièrement les rapporteurs
ainsi que la pr le président de la
commission des lois qui ont permis que
nous parvenions à cet accord ce
compromis pragmatique démontre une
nouvelle fois l'utilité du travail du
Sénat mais une question est maintenant
dans toutes les têtes monsieur le
ministre que va-t-il se passer
maintenant monsieur le ministre j'espère
que vous avez profité de cette semaine
au Palais du Luxembourg car ce n'était
finalement qu'un échauffement minutieux
j'ai bien peur qu'au palais Burbon ce ne
soit bien plus
acrimonieux le Sénat sera naturellement
à l'écoute de ce que feront les députés
mais sur plusieurs aspects du texte vous
avez bien compris que nous pourrons
difficilement transiger nous conservons
l'espoir que le texte qui sera adopté à
l'Assemblée nationale permettra ensuite
d'avoir un dialogue constructif en
commission mixte paritaire mais nous ne
pour pas vous suivre si les apports du
SAT sont systématiquement remis en cause
par la majorité à
l'Assemblée l'examen en commission des
lois qui débutera fin novembre nous
donnera des signaux auxquels nous serons
attentifs pour l'heure le groupe Union
centriste votera très majoritairement en
faveur du texte issu des délibérations
de notre haute assemblée je vous
remercie